hey 42 here in 1883 living on the
islands between Java and Sumatra wasn't
the best idea and to be honest living
anywhere within 100 miles of them wasn't
a great idea Eva why because that's
where the island of Krakatoa was
and little did everyone know but
Krakatoa was about to become the
deadliest place on earth in May a German
warship told of enormous clouds of ash
rising from the peak of Krakatoa the
captain had declared them to be six
miles high and during the moms after
continued sightings of ash clouds were
reported alongside flashing illuminated
clouds and ominous
thunderous noises you'd be forgiven for
thinking that Godzilla was on his way
the inhabitants of nearby island soon
gathered near the coasts and held
festivals in the honor of this
unbelievable natural spectacle and they
all innocently looked on at mighty
Krakatoa and its awesome performance but
what they didn't know was that this
performance was actually a countdown at
12:53 p.m. August 27th the island of
Krakatoa exploded with one of the most
devastating shows of force the world has
ever seen
eruptions of ash trees 24 kilometers
into the sky explosions could be heard
nearly 2,800 miles away in Perth
Australia the detonation itself had an
explosive force of two hundred megatons
of TNT ten times more powerful than the
Mount st. Helens eruption and a nuclear
bomb that detonated over Hashima this
was one of history's mother nature's
been hitting the gym again moments
people were almost immediately consumed
and killed by boiling volcanic rock
fragments and searing volcanic gases but
then something much more horrifying took
the lives of thousands more an enormous
tsunami created by the force of the
eruption swept a wall of water almost
120 feet high across the coastlines of
Western Java and Sumatra that's an
almost 12 story wall
crushing liquid death a rare instance
when a tsunami actually resembled how
it's usually depicted in films entire
islands and 165 coastal towns vanished
beneath the waves completely destroyed a
steamship was carried one mile inland
and all 28 crew members were killed
under Nova turning in time to position
itself to surmount the crest of the wave
looked back to see that the town Navy
nanka dot had been erased from the face
of the earth Mother Nature had hit the
reset button there were 36 thousand 417
deaths in total by far one of the
deadliest and most destructive volcanic
eruptions in history noise of the
explosion even meatwad week as nearly
300 miles away a wave of pressure shot
from the volcano at 1086 km/h 90% of the
speed of South rupturing the eardrums of
sailors 40 miles away in the Sundra
Strait in fact the wave was so powerful
it rounded the entire world three and a
half times when all was said and done
less than 30 percent of the original
island remained adios hasta LaVista
never coming back the lesson here there
are some shockingly deadly places on
earth and if you can help it you really
should avoid them but look I hear you
saying that's 1883 where would it be
wise to avoid today and I understand
there's going to come a time when kovat
finally pisses off and we're all going
to be released into the wild excited to
explore once more but getting it wrong
could cost you more than your plane
ticket it might cost you your life
because there are some countries that
have dangerous places or geological
features such as notorious prisons
sinkholes or certain dangerous
neighborhoods but then there are other
countries so uniquely dangerous as a
whole that your life is just flat-out
more likely to end by
pinkfoot within its borders el salvador
for instance is one place on earth that
you are far more likely than anywhere
else to be murdered by another human
being it has a murder rate of 61.8%
people to give you some context the USA
is roughly four per 100,000
that's over 15 times higher with
interpersonal violence being one of the
leading causes of premature death for
some more context in the UK that role is
filled by cancer and murder is
significantly lower on the list last
year there were only 650 homicides in
total El Salvador's homicide rate has
actually fallen since the 90s but there
are still two to three thousand each
year but there's more to this story and
it's actually much worse than the
statistics suggest you see in El
Salvador you aren't just stabbed or shot
you'll ever be found brutally
slaughtered with like your leg sticking
out of your mouth and your eyeballs
jammed into your wallet or you'll never
be found at all this is perhaps one of
the more disturbing facets of El
Salvador's violent reputation because
disappearances are not included in
homicide statistics after all if no dead
body is discovered where is a homicide
but at the same time disappearances are
unsettlingly common meaning the rate of
murder is probably much much higher than
the one I just mentioned in fact an
article from The Guardian cited three
thousand three hundred and eighty-two
people reported missing that year at the
time of the articles publication
November 2019 the Attorney General
listed 2018 figure as three thousand
four hundred and thirty seven more than
the number of homicides reported those
two years you know I said the homicide
rate is dropping well when you consider
that the disappearance rate is
simultaneously increasing it suddenly
raises a huge red flag most horrifying
of all though those disappearance
numbers were widely seen
an undercount but why the hell are all
these people being killed or
disappearing you're most likely both
what is the cause well in many ways El
Salvador is a country ruled by gangs of
their 6.5 million population 10% is
seriously involved in the criminal
underworld gangs like la 18 ms-13 and
Mara's have a powerful influence on the
country and their citizens controlling
242 activists 267 municipalities and
wildly outnumbering the police on top of
this the gang members are hunted by the
vigilante death squad Sombra negra who
slaughter any gang member they can get
their hands on the result is a country
where death is rampant with almost 11
killings every day this is where the
disappearance is common when there is
nobody there is no evidence meaning
killers wanting to stay hidden or police
wishing to hide illegal executions which
happen by the way are motivated to hide
their bodies it's also probably part of
the government's strategy to reflect a
safer El Salvador and to do that
violence needed to become invisible when
the country is two top gangs formed the
government-backed
truce the inter gang violence and
resulting homicide rate seems to
decrease but the disappearances
increased leading many analysts who
suggest that El Salvador isn't just a
country most likely to see you murdered
it's also one where your body will
probably be hidden to keep the murder
rate down now you may think that's it
and a video
that I'm likely to get murdered got it
well not quite because there's another
country where you're likely to get eaten
alive torn to pieces injected with venom
or simply crushed to death by animals
you might think with its snakes
stonefish spiders emus and dingoes
Australia would be the worst country on
Earth for animal related slaughters but
you'd be wrong there are only 241 animal
related deaths between 2000 and 2010
India blows that figure out of the water
it annihilates it if Australia is the
talented welterweight of animal violence
India is a heavyweight champion of the
world between April 2014 and May 2017
over 1,100 people have been killed by
animals for perspective that's around 8
months
to hit what Australia managed in 10
years in India there are massive 5000
kilogram Indian elephants that go on
rampages flip and crush cars and turn
people into human gel underneath their
enormous feet killing over 250 people
during 2016 to 17 and that's just a
start of it India is also home to the
spawn of Satan itself snakes Indian
Cobras Russell's Vipers saw-scaled
Vipers and Krait are all varieties of
death-dealing snakes you can come across
in India the saw scaled Viper kills 5000
people every year the common Krait
10,000 the Indian Cobra 15,000 the
Russell's Viper 25,000 people every year
total snakebite fatalities are close to
50,000 per year from 2.8 million snake
bites leading the w-h-o to refer to it
as a neglected tropical disease and
global health priority if we do some
maths on that about 7,000 671 bites and
136 deaths
every day eat your heart out El Salvador
those gangs or to start getting Indian
snakes on their payroll with some
elephants to back them up as muscle the
Russell's Viper the most likely
assailant against you and whose name in
Hindi means the lurker produces one of
the most excruciating bites in the known
universe causing internal bleeding
severe swelling necrosis bleeding gums
and genitals blistering vomiting
numbness and of course death if he or
his venomous brothers and sisters don't
get you a big reticulated python can
also wrap itself around you and squeeze
to last gasps breaths of oxygen from
your lungs before you're inevitably
swallowed whole like Jon Voight in the
film anaconda and if you figure well
you'll just stay away from the fields
jungles villages and cities and stick to
the safe beaches there's even a stake in
the sea that can kill you there's
nowhere that's safe cry so Pelle or
Nutter can even fly gliding through the
air as it directs its murderous fangs to
what your jugular
I've heard of some scary creatures in my
time but a god damn flying snake takes
some beating but don't sweat I'm sure
the Taj Mahal is lovely to top it off
there are spiders leopards sloth bears
and lastly gigantic money zing Tigers
one of which the Champa wat
tiger killed over 435 people yes that
was one individual tiger
she makes Jeffrey Dahmer look like a
children's entertainer and during 2016
to 1727 individuals were stalked and
killed by man-eaters
what's in most countries humans and the
animal kingdom pose a limited threat to
your existence as the story of Krakatoa
eruption in 1883 demonstrates the
environment is the real danger the
pleasant Pacific Islands look pretty
good right picture-perfect beaches
crystal-clear waters near year-round
perfect sunshine and more fresh coconuts
than you know what to do with but in the
case of Vanuatu there's a fairly decent
chance your holiday plans would be
interrupted by almost certain
Death Vanuatu is home to cyclones
tsunamis earthquakes and active
volcanoes they're just awaiting a meteor
strike to complete the roster
not only is Vanuatu home to such a
staggering array of disasters but it
also according to the UN you EHS has a
36 percent risk of a natural disaster
occurring every year the most of any
nation in the world on top of this 64
percent in Vanuatu citizens are exposed
to natural disasters each year one year
it was hit by an earthquake then a
volcanic eruption then the largest
cyclones you ever hit the South Pacific
one after the other all in the very same
year and we complain about 2020 all of
this means if you go to Vanuatu you've
got a good chance you're going to get
caught in the middle of a natural
disaster that will pulverize you into
oblivion
but there's another country that knocks
Vanuatu out of its crystal clear water
for total deaths from natural disasters
China according to the UN new EHS metric
China only has an annual natural
disaster risk of 6 to 7 percent but it
has something else going forward of the
10 deadliest natural disasters since
1900 excluding epidemics and famines
China holds five out of the ten places
including first for the 1931 China
floods which were estimated to have
killed as many as 4 million people
potentially as much as all the other
disasters combined so if you spend the
year in Vanuatu disaster is probably
going to hit you what's in China if it
does you're almost definitely going to
die take your pick
so there we have it those are the
countries where you'll be murdered by
other people killed by animals or
obliterated by the weather but there is
one of our method of death which I
haven't mentioned so far and it's
perhaps
the most insidious of all and that's the
country way you're most likely to be
killed but the very thing that is
intended to protect you your own
government I know the US has gotten a
lot of bad press recently surrounding
police violence but there's another
place where the issue actually is
systemic and it puts all that hysteria
into perspective that country is
Venezuela if we take one of the most
basic metrics for measuring a
governmental level of violence toward
its own people the number of deaths
caused by law enforcement officials than
Venezuela rocks in at a whopping rate of
1830 point 2 per 10 million people the
worst on earth by a country mile El
Salvador that old country of sunshine
rainbows and gang warfare swings into
second place with 954 point five for ten
million that's just scraping half the
USA just forty six point six need I say
anymore
a UN report stated that the
extrajudicial killings by security
forces in particular the special forces
had been alarmingly high in 2018 there
were over 5,200 killings in Venezuela
marked as resistance to Authority and
between January and May of 2019 more
than fifteen hundred and sixty people
were killed but given these figures are
the government's own the two number may
be much higher the report also explains
how seven hundred and thirty nine people
had been randomly deprived of their
freedom and almost two dozen wielders of
political immunity had watched as it was
casually stripped from them without any
mercy
in short the government does whatever
the hell it wants and has no problem
killing you a lot of this is down to the
fact that Venezuela is batshit insane
right now and in many ways the most
deadly country on
besides the fact that Venezuela is
filled with deadly animals has its own
problems with criminal gangs has the
second highest murder rate worldwide
rates of kidnapping that's increased
year on year and is dangerously close to
a global hurricane hotspot Venezuela is
also a country that is struggling not to
fall apart the state continually
violates its obligation to support
access to food in healthcare leaving
large portions of the population
starving suffering from malnutrition and
desperate hospitals are understaffed
with little supplies or even the
electricity to keep it running on
between 2018 and nineteen over fifteen
hundred and fifty people died because of
a lack of medicine and equipment and
politically the country is a shambles
how did this occur well to borrow the
parlance of reddits the TLDR of the
situation is hyperinflation sending the
price of everything way up corrupt
politicians power cuts starvation and
just about everything you could want to
make a population and it's oppressive
government as desperate and dangerous as
possible the whole thing is basically an
exercise in how to destroy a country 101
there have even been insane instances of
political opposition leaders having to
break into Parliament's to be sworn in
using entire mobs of their supporters to
help them smash past your fora terian
guards
yeah I know crazy but hey that's what
socialism will do for you so even though
I sincerely wish them well and wish the
people good fortune and a brighter
future I have to say with a vicious
oppressive and ostensibly murderous
government little healthcare little food
a staggering crime rate dangerous rain
forests and swirling nearby storms
Venezuela is definitely the most
dangerous place on earth
so perhaps go to one of Earth's safest
countries instead but I'll save that one
for another video thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video
then please consider supporting me you
can do that by joining the 42 club here
on YouTube or you can head on over to
patreon links for both are in the
description thank you you can also get
your hands on our first edition signed
copy of my new book sticker flagging it
by heading on over to unbound publishing
and pre-ordering your copy today the
links in a description thank you